I've seen a cat take a [ __ ] locking eyes
with my roommate not many people can say
that I have a cat and her name is Genji
his name is rusty Shackelford my cat's
name is tails
Nino so I missed having Harry with me so
I flew him out to LA from Dallas and he
was kind of standing near the wall and I
was petting him and he started having a
sneezing fit he has this problem where
he didn't go to the bathroom for like
three days and then he started acting
like he was like possessed by a demon
and then all of a sudden from the living
room I just like hear this scream and
it's my roommates like what the [ __ ]
dude and it just splattered all over the
wall some [ __ ] flew out his butt in
liquid form onto my shirt dude you can't
[ __ ] [ __ ] all over the beanbag I
don't mean in Tripoli I guess her tail
had been under her and like her whole
dump went on top of her tail
so like three turds for like on her
whole tail like [ __ ] longer than him
came out of him and I have no idea how
it happened this huge love sack in the
living room is just like drenched in
diarrhea like cat diarrhea ever images
it just smells it's like a [ __ ] sauna
just in your face a sheer weight of the
poop on her tail she couldn't handle it
I don't know why she didn't feel it
happening in the mitts but like there
was nothing in the litter box and then
he walked away and my roommate was like
I think we need to get rid of this cat I
don't think it's working out and he told
me like get rid of the cat like the
cat's gotta go or I'm gonna good
we're not friends anymore now but for
other issues I don't know
cat sir it's kind of a sacrifice you
have to make if you want a cat you know
but I love cats so much that it's worth
going through some [ __ ] storms
you